okay for people joining this live stream
we are looking at
a long requested long-awaited set of
features
around interactive highlighting and
interactive graphics
on the desktop and in the cloud we've
had a bunch of we've had the capability
to do all kinds of interactive things
uh in both of those environments for
millions of years
but this is an attempt to standardize
certain kinds of effects on graphics
that people seem to like
all right so let's get started here
um
well that's for sure that that should
never ever happen i don't ever want to
i'm going to delete that that cell
because that's so obvious it shouldn't
even be
mentioned
yes except that
it got it out in the open and so
well then let's put it back there and
and highlight it maybe
yeah i was going to say bold it instead
of delete it
well i think i just pressed the delete
button that's okay
all right okay okay so
cross hairs point highlighting object
highlighting so those are so these are
what are available in cloud
okay
so okay
so this is a free-form
cross-hair
okay
and and so this is something that would
sort of make sense globally at you know
the scene level
this is an instance of
a crosshair that is
tied to that curve
okay
and here we have you know sort of
showing that it's
this is actually oh this is on test is
this deployed in in production it is
it's just i don't like putting stuff on
you know public-facing servers
okay so wait a minute so this is just
pure list plot it doesn't say crosshairs
so this is something that happens by
default for a list
in the build that i had when i uploaded
this notebook
listbot had it turned on by default
i'm confused on a production server or
only on the test server just so
the mechanism used is on production
the code that
turns it on inside this plot is
currently on a branch
i just understand how you actually did
this but so people out there in the
world can't see this right now is that
correct
if they got a hold of this notebook they
would see what you're seeing
okay all right so this is they have no
way of running this notebook okay all
right okay i understand
and and so that's what you were just
looking at is an example of what i
consider a slice
yeah i can see that yeah
well there's a bunch of interesting
functionality here
so let's take a look
so is this
yeah change the appearance of an object
when you mouse over it that's important
okay so i am not a fan look at this [ __ ]
look at this look at this look at this
how did that still happen
how did that still happen i'm not sure
okay that's not good enough
well yeah
i don't know
john can you say something about why
that still happened
um
not without looking at the notebook well
i can see right there bar chart somehow
had some well no i mean dynamics just to
say
all this all the dynamics in the system
got disabled
okay why
why i mean we've been through this many
times
that we have to avoid that
that if you're going to use dynamics
they have to be set up so that they do
not trigger that trust warning
am i making sense yeah making sense
entirely i mean it's it's it's clearly a
bug but i i can't comment on this i know
but it's like they've been there for
like five years or more
no i've reported it like 100 times
no it's it's not it's not one bug it's a
number of bugs
many of which have been fixed and this
one clearly is either new or it wasn't
noticed before i
i don't i don't know whether this was
like a very basic bug because i've i've
seen it a hundred you know thousands of
times i've seen it especially when i've
done this notebook in 12
what when uh well i i i do not think you
will see that warning come up
okay well um i've seen it i think
something has changed in thirteen that
has caused
a lot more
do we really need to look at it in 12-3
i can no no no no no no i'm just saying
i i keep saying just send me the
notebook and i'll deal with it next time
okay all right okay uh andrea can you
forward john the notebook yep i'm doing
that thanks okay
all right
so
what are we looking at here so so what
should i be looking at next
this design or what
i think we should discuss the design
what do we want to name things how do we
want to split it up
um i wish i had seen this before
sorry
um i think roger you and i have looked
at this yeah but they don't want a bunch
of new options i think we want something
that's a little bit more composite
okay so so we have options including
you know the design includes options
including extensions to plot theme
it includes wrappers
um
yeah but let's say crosshairs let's say
that you want a drop line and a drop
plane is that going to be a new option
then
and then you want a
highlight curve is that going to be a
new option then and then you want
um
highlight nearest data points is that
going to be a new option then
i don't think it scales
i mean i don't think
i think
it's a collection of effects
i mean i think you have
a small number of options
that
are quite flexible
so let's talk about the design space
that roger just mentioned right
um can you can you bucket what these
things are
these three
that's that's what we need to do that's
why i said i wish i'd seen this so we
could start bucketing them because these
are
example of prototypes and we have more
candidate things
and but we need to do that overview
before right and so we have
like i have three reference pages that
i've started
one is for crosshairs as an option
one is for
highlighting as an option
one is for highlighting as a wrapper
and the highlighting ones
allow multiple effects to be specified
at the same time
okay explain the following thing to me
okay first question is
why aren't we doing a bunch of these
things by default
maybe we are i that's what we're
discussing now
okay
um
i mean i don't see any reason where why
when you put your mouse
near i mean i i'm not seeing any curve
highlighting here
is there curve highlighting
there is
okay
i i'm not sure what else one would do
when one had one's mouse in the area of
the graphic here
if i mean unless the graphic has
locators and things on it but they have
a definite
uh you know
active region
so i mean
there could also be
i mean what could imagine um
um highlighters yeah exactly the the
things that come up explanations that
come up or events
that come up when you mouse over it
right right
i mean that we already have had we've
had for years we've had tool tip
so no i'm just saying more more of them
like their events yeah like this is
this is the minimum this is when the
stock market crashed this is when
sure you know servers uh exploded
right and
at the moment
labeling type effects
are farther out
um i mean i think they're very
interesting i think there's a lot of
things that can be done there but
neither cloud nor desktop
is ready for them yet right except for
tooltip which we've had forever
right
and i mean there's maybe a a variant of
tool tip
which is
you know
there's a question of when a tooltip is
switched on or not
is that making sense yep
mean it's quite common that
you get you know the information you
know that sort of tooltip like as a
click effect
well
okay
but i mean i'm i'm asking
okay what does that mean i mean once you
have the tooltip you click on it and you
get more or what no i'm saying that you
would get like say point highlighting
by default
and then you have the ability to say
click on the point and it puts up what
the actual values are or additional
information
yes
i understand although it's not clear
what that happens if you have multiple
points here
well you can only click on one of them
at a time
okay
and i mean the other thing that you have
sometimes
which i don't always like the appearance
of is
[Music]
like say your crosshairs
where the actual values are tracking
along the axis and displaying 4.7 or
whatever
yes
um
well there are many such styles and i'm
i would hope that you have a will
you know inventory all of those
but
okay
so
the thing that hasn't been done here
is a proper inventory of all the various
effects that we're looking for
so what you're providing here
is
fairly specific
options
that
you know i don't know i mean the the how
what
types of plots do these apply to
like if i have a parametric plot what
would it do
i mean a parametric plot crosshairs
still make sense
um point or curve highlighting still
makes sense
and these are very general effects
yeah um
i mean
you know there may
there are going to be some special cases
so
crosshairs on a polar plot
should probably not be a normal
cartesian thing it should be a radial in
circle or something yep
um
that's not listed in this notebook but
you know that's an obvious thing well
and and how would this yes right i mean
those are otherwise our coordinate
systems are rectilinear are they not
they might be differently scaled but
they're rectilinear coordinate systems
right apart from polar plot is that
correct
um there's a
handful of exceptions
okay uh polar plots um
the
you know the radial axis plot the radar
okay all right so let's go through then
okay
so
the concept is
there are
there's a wrapper like tooltip
there's some kind of generic but i don't
understand how crosshairs if i want a
particular object to have crosshairs on
it
i do how do i do that so the design i'm
proposing
is that we have
some crosshairs option
because it
you know in the freeform case it has to
apply the whole scene
it doesn't make sense to wrap it around
something
um because it's not going to be tied to
that
and so if you look at the include
crosshairs
a little bit of at the top of your right
so true
is the free form
whatever
automatic is i would make processes
maybe rather than true yeah okay
um
i mean none at all was my first thought
and then okay actually maybe more and
maybe it'll be true false so you might
be right go ahead um but anyway
automatic is
only fire the cross hairs when you're
over something
falses don't show crosshairs
list of values is
you know do it in one direction but not
the other
right and 3d is is is not yet even close
3d is not yet and crosshairs don't make
sense in 3d
well depending on what kind of device
you have
no no no i mean
i mean crosshairs as a line coming from
a point
or at least it's more complicated
because it goes to a place not an axis
yeah i know i know so it drops onto a
plane
right
what's wrong with that seems useful to
me
i mean it i suppose it can be useful um
i mean we've been
working on illustrations with
tim for vis functions that are
you know wherever we've been trying to
figure out what looks good
you know for 3d to drop down and label
coordinates and whatnot
um right
and so
you know it may be that you need two
sets of droplines you need a drop line
to the face and then a drop line from
that point over to the axis or something
um
but
anyway 3d
not yet
okay um
so
that is the first option
which is you know controlling crosshairs
behavior
um
and this totally could be on by defaults
um i think the crosshairs don't out not
very elegant right now there's just a
big black line
at least here
how did we this i think they're a little
bit dark we can
lighten them up
okay
um
but how would we specify things like
being able to click and get coordinates
or even how would we specify getting
crosshairs
where the coordinates are displayed
right at the crosshair position for
example
that would
be
something else
i mean that would be some sort of
labeling feature
um
and i don't think it's part of the
process there's a style of crosshairs
right because i mean there's another
style which is just the point
well i mean look i mean that's not a
crosshair right i mean that is
when you have just the point
and i mean you could do that sort of
labeling
just as easily without the crosshairs
yeah i know i understand
and
so i mean that would probably be
an additional option or effect in
highlighting
um and i think it's a very interesting
one but it's not one that
um
well so
these things that you're showing here
are things you have now implemented
include crosshairs and so on is that
correct
there is a branch with them on it yes
um
and
we can push that branch you know
forwards
you know and roll it out to
lots of things i think
um
but anyway
so crosshairs is one
slice and it's sort of the easiest slice
of you know this set of functionality
um
the next one is
you know how to control
you know sort of the mouse over effect
type
things
and
um
i forget
i think we came up with you know the
current names in the previous round of
this
um and we can certainly change them i'm
not tied strongly to any of them
um
and and for the highlighting you know as
roger points out
there's
a
you know rich space here
and so
there you know the design
for the option and the payload of the
wrapper
are pretty much the same
where you have
some simple forms
and then
more
you know a richer environment for
specifying things okay
um
and so at the simple one you have named
effects
what happens if you want hold on so what
happens if you have multiple curves
and you want to specify i mean like plot
style
there presumably is a way you can
presumably
i mean it's unclear why we call this why
we don't call it like plot highlighting
to go along with plot style
certainly
could i mean maybe it needs the same
syntax as plot style
what about for graph
i i think everything
yeah i mean conceptually
things that work here should work in
graph also
okay so then maybe that's a reason to
not because plot style is obviously not
a thing for graph there it's vertex
style well i mean but i mean
for graph you could very easily
want you know the split of vertex
highlighting versus edge highlighting
yes you could
um
so that and so
calling it plot highlighting then vertex
highlighting edge highlighting wouldn't
be crazy
i i like the plot name space
um
that's what the plot prefix
um i mean particularly if it follows the
same
design as plot style
right
um i mean the other thing that it could
follow
is
gridlock well crust has something like
filling
which allows indexed
specifications yeah but filling has this
feature that it needs to be able to do
pairs
true
which so far as i know this doesn't
i mean unless
how how about highlighting the filling
i mean for the most part
i tend to think of the filling as being
somehow not the content of the plot
you know that things are tied to the
curves not
the filling
um but it's quite possible that
things might need to affect the filling
as well
um
if i give a tool tip
no i i see a tooltip is in a fixed place
so the difference between this stuff and
also
yeah
the most one of the most effective
highlighting mechanisms
is to de-highlight the rest
nothing works as well as that
rather than sort of screaming louder the
other ones go silent more silent
okay
so how does that affect all of this
it could be an an
uh you know a
a uh it's basically a theme for how the
highlighting is done
yeah okay
right i mean so
we'll actually get to roger's case you
know
a little bit in a few minutes i think
um i i don't have it built in as a named
thing yet
um
but so we have named of you know sort of
common types of highlighting effects you
know put a ball on things that
you know is going around
um you know that slice that shows all
the balls
in a vertical column
is a named effect
um
and
as i was saying you know the option
value and the payload for the wrapper
are
essentially the same
um possibly exactly the same
um
and
but if you scroll down a little bit more
there's a longer table
which is
you know sort of
a
method of defining an effect
through sort of an association spec
um and so you can say you know what are
my elements so
um picking a few of these things out of
order
like one of them is persistence
you know whether the highlight earth is
just using smart quotes here sorry
that's a
um probably because of how i typed it in
or something all right okay okay
um okay um
but so so persistent would be you know
essentially whether it's a mouse effect
or a click effect
and you know if you click then it
maintains that state
until you click it again
um
you have things like style so
when the effect isn't you know is
happening what color should it be
um
what about roger's inverse effect kind
of thing so so that would be
um covered by that inactive style at the
top of that table
other event when other elements that's a
weird way to do it because i mean
essentially what you want to do is
change the opacity presumably of
everything else is that right
i don't want to have to go through but
that's one thing we've also
tried
graphs we have the highlight style
you know but um
one is to go sort of
monochromatic throughout right now
okay fine but i mean the
the fact is that we cannot go around
kind of
telling everything what their inactive
style will be because we're going to
miss things and that's going to be a
very inconvenient way to do it
that is a thing that is to be
highlighted above the rest
should be able to say what should happen
to the rest rather than every element of
the rest having to say what will happen
to it if it is unhighlighted
does that make sense
i mean but this
that's essentially what this
is
oh okay no it's not this is an object by
object
specification no no no this is not an
object by object's specification
i mean the implementation may be object
by object no but
it does not
what do you mean but this says style
view is when other elements are
highlighted so if i am downgrading
myself
what style do i use for myself not how
do i
sorry the the wording is
i i think we're just hung up on the
wording i don't think we're going to
worry about the concept
okay so that's the that's the that is
the thing where it globally reaches out
to every other element
and changes its style
correct
so so it's style to use for other
elements when highlighted
yes
yeah no i mean the thing that i was
just thinking about that you made me
think about is you know sort of
what happens if
um yeah that means so one version of
this of roger's d highlight mechanism
would allow you to
you know so like you have a hundred
curves
you know maybe they're all the same
style maybe they're you know different
or whatever
and and you select one and it you know
remains blue and all the others turn
gray
or
80 transparent whatever
and and then
potentially you could then select a
second curve and have it also be active
um and so you have sort of two primary
curves
how would you do that one of them so by
clicking you would select one
correct
and if you clicked another one
then it would also become selected
right
um
and so
then the question is you know sort of if
you've specified this
on different curves with different
inactive styles
which one wins
um
which is you know may end up just being
effectively arbitrary or random or
something but
okay so hold on so we're
let's let's zoom out for a minute okay
so what we're trying to do
first point is
we're trying to figure out what we get
into top level language to be used in
the cloud on the desktop
and are you telling me that everything
that's on this page
were we to approve this language design
would actually work in fairly short
order
is that true or is that not true or are
we designing something for far out
we are
designing
farther than we've implemented
how much further
but not not further than the cloud is
implemented correct
i mean some of this is further than the
cloud has implemented
okay um
i mean so
i mean you you have seen what you know
the
cloud notebook that you were looking at
is
pretty representative
so we have crosshairs we have point
highlighting we have
you know element highlighting yes
um
things that
are like you know pie chart being able
to pop a sector out when you click on it
is possible on desktop but not cloud
um
that's been something that's been there
for years
yes
um
and
it's not my favorite feature because
basically it locks things up when i have
large
you know
it has a habit of freezing graphics
when they're large
remember making sense i don't know
whether it automatically switches itself
up for sufficiently large graphics
i think it does i think everything you
know in that chart family of things cuts
off at like 25 or 50. i don't remember
well maybe it's just the the incredible
annoyance of those dynamic warning
messages that come up for every
histogram
and have done for years despite me
complaining about it a hundred times
and that needs to be tracked down and
fixed but okay
the
um so anyway
the
there's a small core
you know smaller core of the most common
things
that
could roll out
widely relatively quickly
and then there's some things like the d
highlight which are
you know we wanted to make sure that the
design had you know would be able to you
know encompass them
even though we aren't you know at a
point where we can roll it out yet
right by the way it should surely be
saying plot female full highlighting
shouldn't it
yeah probably
okay so
look plot highlighting
seems like a reasonable thing
with a default
that presumably will be
automatic so long as that isn't going to
you know be a performance issue
okay
and i just see no reason why we
shouldn't have that
now in terms of cross hairs
that reminds me of grid lines
and i think that by default crosshairs
should follow the same style as grid
lines
really at least very close to
and should they be there by default i'm
not sure
we've had them by defaulting wolfen
alpha forever and ever
not sure anybody ever noticed but um
i mean
i mean a lot of times we have features
that
um
people like to notice they aren't there
well yeah quite
um
okay
well so what would be the include what
other options are include xxx
and i mean plot highlighting would be
for
in its simple default way would be
for either everything
or for a list of
the plot elements in the same way that
plot style deals with plot elements
right but there are more complicated
things like filling highlighting
which could potentially be handled by a
more elaborate association based syntax
and each individual plot highlighting
could have instead of just red
could have potentially an association
that describes down like the one that
you have down there for the highlighting
wrapper
so highlighting as a wrapper would go
along with and how does that relate to
uh highlighted graph
what is it highlight graph gosh i use it
all the time i don't remember because it
auto completes
um
i think it's highlights
yeah i think you're right but so isn't
there a graph highlighting option
yes
i i think highlight graph is
well highlighted
is different
well i know what it is i use it all the
time i mean it allows you to specify
like a sub graph or points within a
graph and highlight those specific
points within a graph
right
okay so so the question here would be
should there be
is that for example is that useful
functionality for graphics
or plots to be able to reach in from the
outside so there is graph highlight
style
okay
all right but but then but then that's a
bank switched highlight style for the
graph but the important concept is
highlight graph
reaches in from the outside of the graph
and highlights specified elements
yeah right we don't have an analogous
thing for a graphics object
i don't think so
no i mean but whether we want one
so there's graph highlight and there's
graph highlight style
no i understand but graph highlight is
the function the pictures then no graph
highlight is the option well what's
highlight graph highlight graph is the
function okay fine
okay
so what does graph highlight take as an
option i would take it as a value
it it it's a mix of vertices and edges
okay so that's not the same as what
you're proposing here
those are the two elements that exist in
a graph
no i understand that
graph highlight
did i misspell this no it's fifth down
you missed an h h-i-g-h
and what's this
that is just something which draws uh it
basically it draws off no i know but the
question is whether how does that relate
to highlighted highlighting how does
that relate to what's in the graphics
right and
you may notice that i have a note of you
know maybe we co-opt
you know this symbol
i think that would be quite sensible
um i mean it would be extensive taking
one argument right now
why is it two different meanings let's
see
this is
this is a bunch of options there
you know i haven't used this as much as
i should i've had a bunch of
applications but i should have used this
i had sort of forgotten that it existed
i think you said that the last time this
year a couple years ago i was
i was going to ask that but from the
midi notes when we had this several
times ago i'm pretty sure we talked
specifically about this again but yeah
okay so that's an issue which we need to
um
okay so highlight graph
graph highlight so that's a list of
elements
yes which is very different from plot
highlight
plot highlighting i think yeah well i i
understand but so
so
plot highlighting the concept would be
that the elements are specified
positionally in a list
and what is being delivered
is the highlighting theme or style
we've got quite a constellation of
related things here
uh
and and roger you were discussing yet
other
kinds of factoring kinds of
um effects and so on
yeah but that's why i wanted to to have
worked through this before well i know i
know we should have done that yeah but
you know and so yeah it's a big space
and
and when we've exhausted it we kind of
know because things start to look like
noise at the end
yeah and um
and i thought that this is this reminds
me of a prototype we built 10 years ago
because that's when we started in on the
cloud
um
you know to to have these interactive
effects in the cloud
and
i don't think we've revisited it
you know
that was more the
export directly to some framework stuff
yeah
exactly
um to be picked up there you know and
and we had a problem because we
introduced a lot of interactive stuff
and we had many more on prototype like
you click this bar and it would do a
backflip literally
um
you know lots of things that we kind of
ended up not going we tamed it down but
it was still very controversial in the
desktop
to have uh interactivity
well i think we're over that hump
i mean you're talking about the backflip
as in you click a bar it turns itself
around and shows you what a labeling
behind it or something yeah we had all
kinds of i mean that that's not super
important but the fact that it was such
a negative reaction from you in
particular to the interactive graphics
that that we sort of toned it down for
some time to come
well right and maybe the world has moved
on
i mean
i think that
the thing that i don't really like very
much
is
you know the kind of
you know
shiny i mean the kinds of things that
people have thought in the past
would make you know good marketing
presentations
where you know the
the the bar chart
has a shiny
bar that glints in the sun or something
sure right
i mean i think that that
you know there was a period of time when
people were just thrilled about those
kinds of things
um i i kind of feel that time has passed
now the question is of the things that
are actually functionally useful
because i reacted very negatively to
those things and i'm glad we didn't
implement a bunch of those things
um
so now the question is
are things that are functionally useful
i mean
one of the things that keeps holding me
back is performance
because it's not useful if we put in
some fancy feature
and then all plots grind to a halt
or it only works because i think one of
the things that is really different
in a lot of what we do is there's a lot
of programmatically generated diagrams
which can have you know many many curves
they can have you know it's not just a
hand done oh i'll select this column in
some spreadsheet
and you know plot one curve there right
we routinely will have something where
it is a programmatically generated
collection of curves and so on and so we
have different issues
from
something where it's just like every
every curve is hand specified
am i making sense
yeah so we have to be kind of careful
that the things that uh you know the
wizziness and the kinds of features
which are relevant for i've got two
curves artisanally created so to speak
um
you know
different story here
so
but
and i have no idea like i mean if i were
to generate
a hugely complicated plot with a
thousand curves on it
and then i were to ask for crosshairs
what would happen
would it grind to a halt would it still
work what would it do
if it's the free-floating crosshairs it
shouldn't grind it doesn't
right it doesn't care but let's imagine
that it's it's the automatic behavior
automatic behavior
in cloud i think
wouldn't care
i'm not sure about desktop well i mean
it's a hit testing thing
and the question is do we have that
efficiently done or not is it even
plausible to do it efficiently because
if we're hit testing something i mean it
depends on what happens when we have you
know if the whole thing is a giant ball
of wool
yeah
this one here uh no the one in desktop
um so go up to where we had the wolfram
language examples
uh this one here yep
and scroll down
so like that parallel axis plots you
know that's 50 curves
that
remains
very responsive up 500 will be fine
um
that's nice
you know if if you go to 5000 it's gonna
start to lag
well thousand will be just
like
nothing i mean there's nothing to see
yep
um i mean it's going to be blue the
whole thing
it's going to take a minute just laying
everything out
why
is to lay down i'm not sure what it's
taking longer than i think it should
um
so also
one of the issues here is the fact that
you're doing this uh or or that you know
you're implementing this as a mouse over
means that
uh correct me if i'm wrong bret but i
believe that you're
not and cannot take advantage of
multi-line objects
correct it is not a multi-line object
although every line is only there once w
which is which means that at the very
beginning you have an inefficiency even
before you've done mouse overs you have
an inefficiency because
uh
you know instead of having one line box
that contains you know lots of lines in
it you have one line box per line
right
okay but so what should happen in a case
like this this is
there is did you switch off at some
magic number did you switch i i think
that one did switch off at
probably one or two thousand
okay at which point by the way it should
use
the combined line box right by the time
it switched off highlighting it should
be using the combined line box
is it
probably not
yeah well so that's probably an
optimization that hasn't been made yet
right so it's just a bug
right
um and and john and i have discussed
ways of
doing this so that it doesn't
need to use 5 000 line boxes
oh i have to say that discussion i
believe you but that discussion isn't
within my memory uh
we have the discussion and then it
immediately goes out of your memory
again okay that that's important
every version
okay so here this was implemented years
and years ago right
yes this is a quite lovely and very
interactive thing
so one question would be if a user wants
to enter in what is that three halves
times ten to the eighth i was noticing
that
just recently and i'm really curious to
know
right so
if a user wants to implement this
essential functionality how could they
do it
not easily
so this is what yeah so this is what we
have to think about is what what
components do we need to provide so that
this is easy to implement because this
is pretty nice
right and one could imagine in in a list
plot scenario that this thing about
having
discrete elements
of you know with finite width in the
list plot was a thing that was desirable
i mean some list plots are a
representation of a you know a
continuous function
at discrete points and others are
discrete points like this one
and for example the correspondence
between different plots
in a impaneled layout so to speak
seems also relevant
yes exactly
so like the crosshairs would be you know
we would need to make sure that they
work well in multi-panel lands
i mean this is pretty nice
perfectly i don't know how when we did
this ten years ago or more this this
position i think yeah version eight
which is one
um
prior to moving so a dozen years ago
okay so okay so this has been around a
long time so we've had some form of
interactive graphics
for this specific case for a really
really long time
right
you know and that's just a complicated
dynamic module
you know
let's put it this way that output was
not already in the notebook because i
knew it would pop the dialogue
um
i'm not happy about that dialogue i'm
really not happy about it i mean we yeah
we need to stop can we delete it let's
get rid of it
that's what i've been pushing for
for certain cases where we where we you
know we should be able to tell
more carefully whether that you know
whether this is our internal code or
external code if it's our internal code
we shouldn't have that dialogue we can
sign them i mean i know that's what i've
been saying for years
okay
okay so in any case
so this is an example of a you know this
is a this is a great example
and
gosh i mean like this effect of having
that
bar
representing a value there
that wasn't even included in your list
of effects up above was it
or down below it's a variation on the
slice
yes but it's not explicitly included so
the question i mean i think as roger was
saying at the beginning of this meeting
right now there's more explanation of
this design space i don't quite i don't
quite understand why you say it's not
explicit it it seems like a i mean
except for the fact that it's
two-paneled it seems like a
trivial uh variation on slice
well except that it's thick
yeah but that's you can style it it's
just it's it's just a style
is it well i mean it has to be the same
style to have a a slice that is as thick
i mean like for example if these were
varying width
i mean if you can ascribe it a color why
not a thickness it's so i understand
that it should be a fixed thickness or
if these things i mean right now i think
these are you know daily plots but maybe
there's a gap okay
okay well if this is i i i couldn't tell
if this is discreet
then yes there is finance doesn't have
gaps on weekends we can don't even exist
that's okay so
so the discreteness is interesting and
different but the thickness is not
no i agree i agree
i i understand the thickness could be
there but i'm saying the discreteness
which is data-dependent thing
i mean the the idea which is similar to
highlight a single bar in a histogram or
bar chart for instance this is
highlighting
you know something for a discrete i mean
again it has to be described what this
is
uh
i mean
don't we have i mean this particular
type of chart i don't know what this is
the high low close chart it's okay
okay but i mean we we have
the notion of a candlestick chart
disembodied from anything to do with
finance as well right
i think all the examples are pretty much
still financed but yes
right i mean in principle we could have
this for you know i don't know what you
know tides or electricity something or
others or it really wants four values so
it's a
smaller set of
we have other similar things box whisker
yeah box whisker is a similar idea
um
and there is an interactive one where
you can add i don't know why
sorry i don't know why we're not having
this for example plotting weather data
well it could be exactly the same thing
the beginning of the interval the high
low and the close
i mean you could
um i mean
somehow people don't traditionally do
that but
well i'm not sure why i'm not sure why
this doesn't take a time series does it
take a time series it does
why does it say that it doesn't say that
um
it needs to say that okay we'll add that
to the notes so for example if i were to
take taking here if i say
um
air temperature data
for i don't know what you know new york
city or something
and then let's say
um
why is this acting so sluggish
now minus
uh
one month
to now
then i should get a time series out from
that
and i should be able to just say i've
not really thought about doing this
before
that seems unlikely to work
why
because you'd need to say that you want
the daily
per day
that you want you know what it was at
midnight at the beginning of the day
what the high was what the low was
what it was at the end of the day
which you can't compute from the time
series
correct
although it certainly could if you told
it just like
you can say in dateless plot i want a
day
granularity-less plot right
yes i mean that part's not a problem
no but i mean if we could give a
granularity to the candlestick chart
then it could do the same thing
could it not
what's in that data does it have four
values
no no it does not it it has one value
but but if you took
if you aggregated it
well okay so so i suppose the missing
function is given
a time series every 15 minutes or every
five minutes or whatever it is during
the day
right
aggregate that into a daily open high
low close
yeah right
um percent 17
indeed
anyway it does seem like we should be
able to leverage those functions for
more
um i mean those functions have been
rather
uh
you know so i mean what would rather
those functions have been rather
isolated
and not connected i mean that's nice
functionality there
um
but those same basic ideas we should be
able to use for other interactive
plotting
right and
right i had mentally clasped that as
slice but
you know without addressing the
thickness issue
right
look it seems to me and we should
probably wrap up here but it seems to me
that that term
the main
look the main takeaway is more
exploration in this design space and
let's come back in a week or two
and let's look at this again when was a
bit more exploration of the design space
and we decide you know we're not gonna
you know
uh gulp down the whole thing immediately
but at least once we know what that
design space looks like we can decide
what corner of it we're actually
introducing for the upcoming version
that seem fair
sounds good i mean i i think you know
we've talked through a few of the issues
here
and i'm a little concerned about the
seven different forms of highlighting
and so on and highlighting
uh
you know
by
well i mean look with styling we have a
perfectly successful thing happening
with plots where you can either do it
from an option level plot style arrow
red green blue or you can do it as a
wrapper i think that is a successful
thing to do everybody agree with that
so i think that the idea of doing that
same kind of thing here for highlighting
is a good idea
i also think that factoring the styling
from highlighting is a good idea and we
don't want to try and have some
interwoven you know style and
highlighting thing
can you elaborate a little bit
well i mean so we could imagine
something where you could have as a
style designator
red but it isn't actually red it's
something that says you know
highlighting only of red
see what i'm saying contingent styling
right
which i think is
[Music]
along the lines of what
john keeps
pushing out of his mind
um which is that there would be
uh faults sorry
um that
um i forgot there were two in this
meeting um
that we could have
a graphics directive
that you know sort of was
what is
the style to apply on when you mouse
over a thing
i said you're saying so that is
so i mean it would be like
i mean because that has all kinds of
issues because
there are many different forms of
mousing you know right clicking and you
know touch interfaces and you know who
knows what some vr ar thing and so on
um
so i mean what are we trying to say here
we're we're um
um
you're saying
there could be almost like an event
handler
for different types of actions
these are different restylings of this
element is that right
i wasn't going that far
but i mean that i mean i i was just
saying you know you know suppose we
let's call it focus style
as
a rapper
well or hover style or click style i
mean there are many different kinds of
actions that you can take on an element
yes there are i mean um this is what a
typical kind of event based system would
say you know on click do this
right and then you go to an ipad and
it's
really weird
um
and and which is why i said focus
because
that was an attempt to abstract between
you know a mouse-based thing and a touch
thing and
but we're basically still saying there
is a restyling that happens
which by the way in this idea of you
are
there and everybody else is quieted
is you know that's already a
you know that then who gets to win if
there are two different
things that are trying to you know
uh
quiet down the other elements
and they're both somehow in focus
see what i'm saying who gets to win the
global war
right and
i mean it depends on what your mechanism
is you know if it's a mouse over type
effect then you know presumably one does
win
you know based on you know who hit tests
first or whatever
okay um
you know if it's a click thing and it's
a little bit more persistent then
i can pick out the curves for the uk and
for the us
and compare them out of everything else
in the world
right
right no that's a nice thing to be able
to do
right
and i mean there's also the possibility
of a selector that is you know a legend
based selector you click the legend and
that highlights the curve
yep those are common also um right so so
as roger has said design space needs to
be explored and i think so there is an
even more exciting thing because we're
looking at high dimensional
visualizations
we're going to look at low dimensional
projections and you've got to be able to
sort of you click in one panel and mark
something up as one panel you've got to
see them light up in the other panels
well quite yes you know and so but
there's a lot of ways you know a lot of
these things you pointed out efficiency
things is a key thing
uh scalability
um
and so some of it can't be done all the
way you know right away because
that's just not gonna be that's fine
but okay
of you know sort of selecting things and
having it
you know affect other things more
remotely
we we need to wrap up here but and
actually there's a another live stream
coming right up about tree outlines
um
which might be kind of related but who
knows
uh
okay so i mean we're just warming up on
this topic so let's try to
meet about it before too long and
come back with slightly more
i mean i think we're realizing
that
you know there are a variety of ways
that you could poke at an object
and we got you know
specifying how you could poke
and what to do when you poke
seem to be like the obvious
issues yep that is you know you could
poke with a legend you could poke from
uh
you know you could you could but it's
hardly a poke but you could specify it
at the level of the outer plot etc
um
yeah and i think the most important
thing for the design is
to leave it you know flexible enough
that
you know
as we come you know if there's a whole
new paradigm of you know some sort of
thing that becomes popular in 10 years
or something that
it's just another
lever that gets added to
yeah
right
um right i mean i suspect that the most
obvious
coming attractions will be various kinds
of multi-selection
natural forms of multi-selection that
never really took off on the ipad i mean
we had in the you know some touch press
products we had um
uh you know things where you could you
know have 10 fingers on the ipad or at
least five fingers on the ipad as
multiple you know manipulate this
molecule with five touch points
um
but i don't think that kind of
uh idea just like shaking i i've not
seen this interface but i mean it was
the case when
when i think it was iphones first came
out that there was the shake action that
could cause things to happen
to undo
yeah it wasn't still iphones
really does it work still
um and at least one of my the apps that
i use regularly yes
wow
it does i'm always doing it by accident
huh wow okay that's a that's a high
discoverability feature
um
okay anyway we should we should wrap up
here thanks guys and